or enabling the freedom of Wireless
charges if you look back at the history
of the iPhone one thing is pretty clear
Apple was late to the game with many
features adding specific
to their competitors but in many cases
they did it right so right that today
they've even surpassed their Rivals so
in this video I'm going to walk you
through the best examples of this but
the main one I want to talk about is the
five to six x Periscope zoom lens coming
to the iPhone 15 Pro Models which has
been confirmed by various sources like
Jeff Pooh the elect unknowns 21 and Ming
shikwo who's been saying the 15 Pro Max
is getting this new foldable zoom lens
for a long time but of course we all
know that apple is late very late
Samsung has Auto insist the s20 ultra in
2020 and Google has had one since 2021
not to mention the dozens of other
Android phones that already have
Periscope lenses but in my opinion apple
is going to have a completely different
take to this coming right out of the
gate with the number one Periscope
camera on any phone ever so let me
explain why first of all we already know
that the case renders for the iPhone 15
Pro Max show three camera bumps just
like the smaller pro model which isn't
getting the Periscope this year so how
does that make sense shouldn't the pro
Max have a fourth lens or at least look
different in some way on top of that
unknowns 21 just confirmed that the
Periscope lens will now be in the place
of the current Ultra wide lens which is
in the middle right here right below the
Flash and yes the current 3x lens is
completely going away so how is Apple
going to add a periscope lens with
between 5 to 6X Zoom because this
essentially will create a huge gap
between the regular 1X main camera and
that Periscope lens photos taken at
anywhere between three to the Periscope
will look terrible well I think I have
the answer this new Periscope lens is
not going to be a traditional one like
we see in other phones it's going to be
a periscope with optical zoom built in
so it'll likely be able to cover the
entire range from around 3x Zoom to 5 or
6X just like a real zoom lens on a pro
camera by using layers of glass and a
magnet to zoom in and out within the
iPhone don't believe me well Sony's
Xperia one mark IV from last year
already has an optical zoom Periscope
camera being able to dynamically Zoom
between around 3.5 x and 5x and if you
didn't already know Apple uses so many
sensors in their iPhones because they're
Simply the Best so they already have the
connection to make this happen and to me
the only way it makes sense to
completely replace the 3x lens with the
5 to 6X Periscope is if the Periscope
has optical zoom and in my opinion I
think Apple could easily get a customer
version that can extend the range from
3x to 5x making it much better for Zoom
shots and I'm sure the rest of the
industry is gonna follow so yes apple is
going to be late but only because they
intentionally waited for optical zoom
Tech to be ready so they're gonna do it
right so now let's get into some more
examples of how apple is using this late
tactic for one thing we have the ultra
wide camera Apple was very late to add
this but when they brought it they
brought a feature that matches the image
perfectly between all three of the
lenses so you don't notice any
difference in the color shift contrast
brightness or anything it's perfectly
seamless when you transition especially
when you're recording video and that is
a huge feature because in the past it
would be so noticeable when you switch
between lenses especially when you take
a regular photo and then a zoomed in
photo and the colors don't match but
between them that was terrible and on
top of that the quality of the ultra
wide also was very good compared to
their Rivals so right out of the gate
Apple did it right now moving further we
also have wireless charging which Apple
was very late to add it was very funny
because iPhone fans said that wireless
charging was a gimmick nobody needed it
it was slow the cable was better but of
course Android was right because Apple
ended up adding it to the iPhone 8 plus
and the iPhone 10 and of course it was
very very nice to have however Apple
ended up making it the best out of any
other company because they added macsafe
yes the magnetic charging that makes
sure it's perfectly aligned giving a
good charge not heating up too much and
you can still use your phone while the
puck is on the back or of course there's
so many accessories that you can use
like a wallet on the back or mounting it
in your car it is just so convenient
it's literally my favorite iPhone
feature and it's so good that it's
becoming the industry standard G 2.0 for
all phones including Android phones
which I think are gonna start getting it
later this year so yes Apple was late
but they did it right and then of course
we have the foldable phone apple is
here's behind Samsung and other Android
devices and why well I believe they're
waiting for the technology to advance
before they move in on foldable phones
because we know there's a massive
difference between the first fold from
Samsung and the newer z-fold four it's
on a whole another level and we also
have Google's new pixel fold and while
it's very nice and thin those bezels are
massive it honestly doesn't look that
great and we know that Apple has been
working on display Tech to get the
bezels even thinner with the iPhone 15
Pro supposedly having the thinnest
bezels in any phone ever 1.5 millimeters
so it is going to be very nice when
Apple comes out with their own foldable
iPhone so they're waiting to get it
right on top of that we also have USBC
which Apple is very late to because
they've been using lightning for the
last decade and it's way overdue they're
rumored to finally switch to USBC this
year however apple is gonna do it
different they're gonna take it to the
next level because we had rumors from
analyst 941 that apple is planning to
give the Pro Models this year
Thunderbolt ports right away not just
USBC but Thunderbolt which no other
phone has right now allowing you to
connect an external monitor for a live
camera feed and also for insanely fast
transfer speeds so once again Apple is
very late but they're going all out and
doing it right so with that said we can
see the trend of Apple doing this over
and over again and but as we know it is
intentional and in the end they end up
with features that are right there with
their Rivals at the top or even
surpassing them in some cases and I
think they're going to do that with the
Periscope lens on the 15 Pro Max this
year so hopefully you enjoy this video
and if you did click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign
[Music]